würden sie aktuell Hamburger Firmen
raten in China zu investieren ich glaube
das müssen sich hier deutsche
Unternehmen gut überlegen Investitionen
im Ausland ist immer ein Risiko und wie
die Entwicklung Chinas in den nächsten
Jahren ist schwierig die kommt zu Ihnen
und würden sie fragen jetzt aktuell und
sagen Bürgermeister ich wir haben ein
bisschen Geld übrig da gibt es diesen
gigantischen Markt 1,4 Milliarden
Menschen das ist das Potenzial das ist
die Zukunft wir müssen expandieren
sollen wir investieren ich würde ihn
raten mit denjenigen zu sprechen die ich
schon in china investiert sind das hat
in den letzten Jahren ja viele
Investitionen aus Europa aus Deutschland
in China gegeben und die Berichte der
Unternehmen die dort vor Ort sind die
ich höre in Hamburg sind dass es in der
Tat seit vielen Jahren eine Entwicklung
gibt die in eine problematische Richtung
geht das ist kein neues Phänomen
mein Eindruck ist in den letzten Jahren
war man zu unkritisch gegenüber China
und jetzt
schlicht die Stimmung so ein bisschen
ins Gegenteil um und wir sollten ihn
abraten eher ich würde das ich gerade
gesagt habe ich würde mit denen sprechen
die investiert sind ich es gibt eine
Reihe an Unternehmen in Hamburg die
Auslandsstandorte in China haben die in
der Straße die entstehen das ist vor
einigen Jahren sehr gute Möglichkeit war
dort unternehmerisch tätig zu sein das
aber dann die Kontrolle und die
Einflussnahme des der chinesischen
Regierung und technischen Partei
strenger wurde und das ist eben auch
Risiken gibt dann für den Betrieb zum
Beispiel von Produktionsstätten welche
Angst haben die welche welche Sorgen
haben die nee es geht darum dass dann
über Nacht gesagt wird es gibt eine neue
Regel also ich sag jetzt mal ein
Beispiel da wird eine neue umweltauflage
beschlossen und dann kommt über Nacht
die Ansage dass diese jetzt einzuhalten
ist und sonst muss die fabrikschlägel
dicht werden das heißt sehr sehr strikte
Vorgaben
ich habe gehört dass können die
Unternehmen dann besser berichten dass
Mitglieder der Kommunistischen Partei in
den Betrieben plötzlich auftauchen und
mitsprechen über die
Unternehmensstrategie also schon
schwierigere Bedingungen als das noch
vor einigen Jahren der Fall und was hat
sie in den chinesische Investoren in
Hamburg über die Situation in China also
ich spreche mit Chinesen die die China
gut kennen die aber eben auch lange Zeit
zum Beispiel in Hamburg leben die auch
berichten dass die Bedingungen
schwieriger werden
die aber von hier aus auch ein besseres
Verständnis haben darüber wie Chinesen
die Welt sehen und wie sie auf Europa
blicken und es gibt schon eine
übereinstimmende Resonanz die sagt oder
einer übereinstimmte Bericht die sagt es
wird schwieriger auch für Chinesen aus
dem die hier leben aber Kontakte zu
ihren Familien in China pflegen es ist
schon eine Zeit in der es strenger wird
und deswegen ist die Diskussion die
geführt wird derzeit dass wir uns
überlegen müssen wie ist unsere
Strategie wie können wir Abhängigkeiten
verringern wo sind überhaupt kritische
Abhängigkeiten die hatte ich schon sehr
wichtig
so
all das jetzt sagend und all das wissend
sie wissen was die nächste Frage ist ja
die werden mich fragen welchen Einfluss
wir China in unserem Hafen einnehmen die
Antwort lautet keinen Einfluss ich würde
sie gerne fragen wenn Sie all das Wissen
sie alles auch so präzise beschreiben
warum kommt man dann ausgerechnet jetzt
auf die Idee
chinesische Investments im Hamburger
Hafen zu lassen das ist etwas was wir
sehr wohl bedacht haben es ist in ganz
Europa in allen europäischen Häfen so
das ist ein Argument für sie tun ja
lassen Sie mich eben sagen die großen
Reederei wir haben fünf weltweit große
Rede rein eine davon ist aus China die
vier anderen großen Reedereien sind
europäische Reedereien und diese großen
Reedereien haben sich in den letzten
Jahren in ihrem Geschäftsmodell so
entwickelt dass sie sich an Terminal
beteiligen an terminals in Rotterdam in
Antwerpen bisher nicht in Hamburg wir
haben nur eine Reederei die bisher
beteiligt war aber Leute und wir haben
festgestellt dass in den
Geschäftsmodellen der Reedereien Ladung
dorthin gebracht wird wo
Rede rein an Terminal beteiligt sind und
es geht in diesem Fall darum dass
Rotterdam und Antwerpen seit vielen
Jahren alle Rede rein bei sich hier im
Hafen haben und wir jetzt damit beginnen
bevor gleich zu Frau Krüger kommen und
dann auch zu Herrn Bachmann wie viele
Beteiligungen an chinesischen Häfen hat
hapag-loud aber Gott Leute hat keine
Beteiligung an chinesischen Hilfen sie
haben Beteiligung jetzt gerade in
anderen
[Musik]
Südamerika zum Beispiel in China das ist
eine unternehmerische Entscheidung aber
um Ihre Frage nochmal aufzugreifen die
hier in der letzten Wochen auch
besprochen wurde dürften die das gibt
europäische Reedereien wie zum Beispiel
märz die Beteiligung an chinesischen
Termin jetzt haben wie viel das habe ich
jetzt nicht nachgezählt was sind mehrere
es gibt ja noch eine andere Hamburg Süd
zum Beispiel auch großes
Logistikunternehmen haben die
Beteiligungen chinesischen mittlerweile
leider nicht mit haferkleid fusioniert
sondern in der dänischen Reederei im
ersten so dass wenn man so will die das
neue die neue großräderei Merz und damit
haben direkt an terminals in China
beteiligt ist
Frau Krüger wenn Sie das Hören das
klingt alles nach einem harmlosen
Investment und Adventure argumentiertum
sorgten höher das haben die ja überall
sonst aus übrigens auch detaillierte
Gründen weswegen mit dieser
Minderheitsbeteiligung im Hafen besteht
weil der gelegentlich gesagt hat
Minderheitsbeteiligung gedacht ne doch
es war von Anfang an 35 % ja seine
Minderheitsbeteiligung und aber eine 35
% für wozu zu Mitsprache recht es ist
eine Minderheitsbeteiligung aber für
Mehrheitsbeteiligung bleibt den
städtische Hand und die Dachgesellschaft
die aller Entschuldigung auch eine
Mehrheitsbeteiligung Hamburg sondern
insofern ist sichergestellt dass es
keine keine unternehmerischen
Entscheidung gibt die gegen die
Interessen Fragen 35 und jetzt 24.09 die
24 9 hat die Bundesregierung zur Auflage
gemacht das war von Hamburg aus nicht
vorgesehen zu Recht
aus meiner Sicht nicht aber ich finde
die 24,9% Beteiligung eine eine gute
Lösung wichtig ist sie 35 mit Mitsprache
von das ist unternehmerisch verhandelt
worden zwischen der Haller unserer
terminalgesellschaft die mehrere
Terminals betreibt die und betreibt das
ist ihre ihr ihr Havel ist das ja der
Hafen ist sowieso Hamburg ja der Betrieb
des Hafens ist
unternehmerisch verhandelt worden nichts
damit zu tun doch die Termine der
Gesellschaft Haller ist eine
Aktiengesellschaft dies börsennotiert
und die governetz will ist das
unternehmerische Entscheidung dort
getroffen werden in diesem Fall ist es
so dass nach dem Außenwirtschaftsgesetz
die Bundesregierung eine solche
Beteiligung genehmigen muss das hat sie
getan und sie hat festgestellt dass es
hier nicht um eine Beteiligung an einer
kritischen Infrastruktur geht sondern um
eine Minderheitsbeteiligung die
genehmigungsfähig also 35% haben sie
nicht genehmigt die Bundesregierung und
sechs Ministerien waren explizit dagegen
das wird gesagt wir wissen mittlerweile
Herr Lindner hat sich öffentlich
geäußert
als FDP Minister
das ist eine sehr vertretbare
Beteiligung ist und das ist eben nicht
um die Beteiligung an einer kritischen
Infrastruktur geht weil es ein
Bundeswirtschaftsminister und
Vizekanzler hat letzte Woche hier gesagt
er würde es immer noch nicht machen und
ich sage wer den Hamburger Hafen kennt
und wer das Geschäftsmodell der
containerlogistik kennt weiß dass das
eine sehr vertretbare Beteiligung ist
die keinen Einfluss auf die auf die
Unternehmen
haben
nur ein Einsatz noch also wenn das alles
kann Einfluss hat dann muss man es ja
nicht machen ne doch weil es einfach
lassen seine unternehmerische sinnvolle
Entscheidung die ladungsbindung nach
Hamburg bekommt und dies uns ermöglicht
unseren Hafen der ja bekanntermaßen
jetzt in der Bedeutung erkannt wurde in
Deutschland
effizient und unternehmerisch
erfolgreiche werden lässt denn wir sind
in einer Wettbewerbsposition mit
Rotterdam und Antwerpen in den seit 20
Jahren und was weiß ich wie lange
selbstverständlich auch Kosten beteiligt
ist frau Krüger also die Beteiligung von
cosco an Rotterdam und Antwerpen liegt
auch unter 20 Prozent also ist sogar
noch geringer wie hoch wenn es einmal
knapp 20 Prozent und einmal glaube ich
gucken die jetzt Fusion
die Überlegung ist der Hamburger Hafen
denkt cosco ist beteiligt und wird waren
Ströme dorthin lenken das ist ja die
Überlegung damit es Wachstum gibt es ist
aber so dass cosco einen Ring gelegt hat
um Europa und an ganz vielen Hilfen
wirklich beteiligt ist und dadurch
Informationen bekommt die ungeheuer
wichtig sind es geht vielleicht gar
nicht so darum Vetorechte zu haben aber
das Geschäftsmodell zu kennen und
wirklich interne Informationen zu
bekommen und so auch die Standorte
gegeneinander auszuspielen und am Ende
der Geschichte könnte stehen das gar
nicht mehr waren nach Hamburg kommt
sondern aus diesem Grund weniger
das ist eine sehr seltene Sichtweise auf
diesen Fall denn es gibt keine Daten die
durch eine terminalbeteiligung eine
Reederei mehr oder weniger bekommt die
Reedereien ob sie eine terminbeteiligung
haben oder nicht bekommen die Daten von
unserer hPa die sie brauchen in den
Hafen hineinzufahren wieder
herauszukommen und die Beteiligung an
sich führt zu keinem Zugriff auf
kritische Daten oder ähnlichen man hat
aber Auskunftsrechte aber
selbstverständlich wenn man an etwas
beteiligt ist zum Beispiel nach dem GmbH
gesetzt da hat man Auskunftsrechte
deswegen ist es ja auch entscheiden das
ist eine Betriebsgesellschaft eines
Terminals ist und nicht die eigentlichen
kritischen Daten die möglicherweise die
Haller Strategie betreffen dort
verfügbar sind die Haller der
hallervorstand hat dieses sehr wohl
sorgfältig bedacht und hat es so
verhandelt dass die
ladungsbindung an diesem Terminal einer
von mehreren in Hamburg gesichert ist so
wie das die anderen Häfen als Strategie
auch verfolgen und kein keine
strategischer Einfluss weder auf die
Haller noch
schon recht erst recht nicht auf den
Hafen insgesamt können wir doch mal
netterweise bitte an die Regie die Karte
zuspielen die wir eben gesehen haben ist
ziemlich beeindruckend ist der Ring Frau
Krüger den sie gerade beschrieben haben
sieht man nämlich sehr sehr deutlich an
wie vielen Häfen allein in Europa oder
rund ums Mittelmeer
chinesische Staatsunternehmen
mittlerweile Beteiligungen haben Piräus
zu 100% auch interessant Genua und
Triest wird gerade mit Hilfe anderer
chinesischer Staatsunternehmen ausgebaut
das heißt in Zukunft wird dort noch mehr
fragt über diese helfen abgewickelt und
ich habe ein bisschen eine Idee davon
warum Peter changer als Hamburger
Bürgermeister gesagt wenn wir das nicht
mitmachen dann werden wir uns irgendwann
einfach abwürgen schlicht und ergreifend
weil jeder wie viel der Container im
Hamburger Hafen aus China kommt jeder
dritte ungefähr jeder dritte das ist
eine macht schon jetzt Beteiligung das
heißt wir haben ein hohes handeln wenn
sie nicht zu denen
ganz Europa hat ein großes handelt
gewesen das ist doch die Verteilung ich
mache in der Angebot dass sie nicht
ablehnen können na das ist wie bei
anderen rädereien deswegen habe ich auch
eine Offenheit das andere Reedereien
sich in Hamburg beteiligen weil es für
die Reedereien genau wie für Hapag Lloyd
und Nasen und andere sinnvoll ist
effizient zu arbeiten indem sie wissen
sie haben sichere Anlaufpunkte und
können ihre Ladung in diese Häfen planen
wir reden hier über Beteiligung von
chinesischen Staatsunternehmen lass uns
die Karte bitte noch mal zeigen
allesamt alle diese helfen waren mal in
öffentlicher Hand oder sind es zum
größten Teil noch
und dann sagen wir das ist nicht
strategisch das ist irgendwie das ist
China ist die größte
Seemacht dieses Planeten
das ist wichtig ist
von cosco eine eine eine Strategie
Schwierigkeiten die die sie machen ganz
gezielt wie hat denn die Bundesregierung
gegründet dass sie nicht 35 sondern nur
24,9 % weil sie unter diese kritische
Minderheitsbeteiligung von 25%, das
müssen sie die Bundesregierung Fragen
ich weiß dass sie haben doch mit den
geredet ja aber mein Eindruck ist das
dort von dass dort eine eine nicht
plausible Diskussion geführt worden ist
zwischen den Ministerien da sind ab da
sind allgemeine Sätze gesprochen worden
china ist ein systemischer Rivale also
sollte man jetzt bitteschön das ist
nicht falsch aber man diese wichtige
Diskussion darf man nicht an falschen
Beispielen führen das ist mein Punkt es
gibt viele Dinge über die wir uns
Gedanken machen müssen aber
in der maritimenschifffahrt beim
Transport von Containern über die Welt
haben wir keine systemische Abhängigkeit
von China in vielen anderen Bereichen
schon und ich sage noch einmal auch die
anderen großen Reedereien Hapag Lloyd
mask beteiligen sich strategisch auf in
der Welt an Terminals im Ausland wir
haben Terminal
aber so gut wie gar nicht in China März
hat sie auch in China und ich sage auch
das muss man natürlich als als
Investitionen als Unternehmen prüfen ob
man das Risiko einer Auslandsinvestition
eingehen Herr Bachmann lebt in den USA
oder arbeitet dort lehrt dort es gibt
auch in Amerika ne Beteiligungen der
Chinesen in Häfen Los Angeles ist zum
Beispiel ja allerdings muss man sagen
dass die Amerikaner natürlich gerade in
letzter Zeit
deutlich schärfere Industriepolitik
gegenüber China machen und sich
sozusagen
amerikanische Staats Bürgern gedroht hat
sie auszubürgern wenn sie weiter für
chinesische
Halbleiterhersteller arbeiten dann
neuerdings den Boykott von Huawei
Technologie also Amerikaner fahren da
interessanterweise dauert eine deutlich
härtere Strategie der verboten Maschinen
von ASML also genau dieser dieser Firma
aus den Niederlanden genau eines der
wertvollsten aber unbekanntesten
Unternehmen der Welt wir Amerikaner
fahren
um diese Transistoren in Milliarden
Menge auf Fingernagel große Chips drauf
zu kriegen das können nur die und da
kommen die Amerikaner und sagen das
verkauft die nicht an die Chinesen wenn
nicht gibt wenn doch gibt's riesen Ärger
naja klar
machen da ihre Macht aus ich würde auch
sagen
Schritt zurückzudrehen was Kosten angeht
ich würde auch sagen dass wenn man ganz
enge Brille auf diese eine Beteiligung
sieht und dann noch mit der Reduktion
der Beteiligung sieht würde ich auch
eher entspannt sehen ehrlich gesagt also
ich würde mir auch tatsächlich mehr
Sorgen machen
um die Investitionen die deutsche Firmen
jetzt in China machen denn das gibt es
ja eine offensichtliche Asymmetrie denn
die chinesischen Beteiligung die die bei
uns machen die stehen ja sozusagen in
deutschen Rechtskreisen wenn China
möglicherweise angenommen China würde
jetzt Taiwan überfallen dann hätten wir
natürlich Sanktionsmöglichkeiten das
heißt sie haben mir zunächst mal sich in
unsere in unseren rechtsreisen in
unserer Abhängigkeit begeben das ist
genau umgekehrt bei Investitionen die
deutsche Firmen in China machen wenn es
da ähm kritisch wird dann sind diese
Investition möglicherweise Weg müssten
abgeschrieben werden und dann kann man
sich auch ausrechnen dass dann auch an
die Politik gegangen wird und sozusagen
nach bellouts gefragt wird dann insofern
manchmal da mehr Sorgen aber wenn ich
jetzt mal Ökonomen holt mal runter
nehmen und mir ist so ein bisschen
breite politisch angucken die die
Umstände des Ganzen sind doch fand ich
schon bemerkenswert also einerseits ein
Bundeskanzler der im Grunde genommen
noch mal so als Vize erste Bürgermeister
irgendwie agiert hat waren so mein
Eindruck der das gegen seine Minister
durchgedrückt dagegen seine
Geheimdienste und dann die Frage ist
halt
wirklich Zeitpunkt der Zeitpunkt auch
mit Russland und der Konstellation und
und drittens ist es genau diese
strategische Entscheidung man hätte man
kann das ja machen aber ich frage mich
was tut der Hamburger Hafen was tut die
Bundesregierung dass man einfach zum
europäischen Thema auch zu machen
in Brüssel spätestens jetzt als Anlass
zu nehmen zu sagen Freunde wollen wir
das eigentlich weiter so machen uns
gegenseitig ausspielen zu lassen oder
könnte gibt es ein europäische
koordinationsmechanismus der dann
entsprechend wenn die Beteiligung schon
da sind dass man die sagen was der
strategisch dagegen setzen kann also die
chinesische Geld nehmen aber es
strategisch im Falle des Falles dagegen
setzen kann und da frage ich mich
komplett das gleichzeitig gemacht das
ist ein glaube ich ein wichtiger Punkt
und wenn wir eine neue China Strategie
aufstellen dann müssen wir das in der
Tat europäisch machen und können nicht
einem einzelnen Hafen auf die die
Spielregeln aufdrücken und sagen alle
anderen machen das weiter was Branchen
üblich ist die Frage wird
Herr Scholz weiß wie der Hamburger Hafen
organisiert ist das unterscheidet ihn
vielleicht von einigen Bundespolitikern
die sich dazu geäußert haben ich will
nur sagen wir sind schon vor zehn Jahren
kritisch gewesen und haben gesagt wir
müssen zum Beispiel verhindern dass
Hapag Lloyd in asiatische oder
chinesische Hände fällt deswegen sind
wir als Stadt eingestiegen unter die
Protest übrigens der gesamten Opposition
bei Hapag Lloyd und sind froh dass wir
es gemacht haben denn eine ziemliche
Sicherheit der hapaklord sonst heute
eigentlich chinesische Reederei und
deswegen müssen wir nicht auf dieses
vordergründige da kauft jemand einen
Anteil einer Gesellschaft achten sondern
wir müssen darauf über wir müssen
überlegen was ist eigentlich unsere
Antwort auf die chinesische
Seidenstraßen Strategie genau und
darüber rede ich übrigens seit einigen
Jahren weil das was wir hier bei den
Beteiligungen im Hafenbereich sehen wir
auch ein anderer Infrastruktur und
deswegen ist es gut dass man in
Deutschland diese Diskussion führt wo
sie sagen
ja wir haben zum Beispiel
Chip-Produktion Werkstätten die verkauft
wurden an zu 100 Prozent man chinesische
Eigentümer auch in Hamburg man sieht auf
jeden Fall was für Chips das sind
hightech-chips die zum Beispiel in der
Automobilindustrie eingesetzt werden
wann ist das wann ist das Überleben vor
einigen Jahren passiert und haben sie da
schon Bürgermeister
ich glaube nicht aber ich will nur sagen
wir waren viele Jahre unkritisch und
sollten deshalb wenn wir jetzt so eine
Diskussion führen sollten wir eine
Analyse machen wo sind wir kritisch
abhängig und das betrifft bestimmte
Produkte das bestimmte Branchen das
betrifft
sicher auch die Vernetzung was wir ja
mit der Seidenstraßen Strategie in China
erkennen ist dass sie sich strukturell
und systematisch Zugang zu den
Weltmärkten verschaffen und wir haben
das alles sozusagen dem Spiel der Kräfte
überlassen und sind zum Teil als als
Stadt Hamburg durch europäisches
Wettbewerbsrecht gehindert worden zum
ein bisschen unsere Hafenbahn zu
investieren wir müssen also in Europa
eine Diskussion führen wie wir uns
strategisch besser aufstellen und wir
brauchen das sage ich immer eine Antwort
auf die chinesische Seidenstraßen
strategieale geben kann jetzt sagt jetzt
haben die Hamburger gesagt weil die
anderen das machen machen müssen wir
auch nicht verstehen
jetzt müssen wir noch zulegen vielleicht
die Beteiligung und am Ende ist das
Ergebnis dass alle immer mehr abhängig
von China werden und deswegen
Koordination deswegen da anschließend
sie dürfen wirklich sofort aber die
Frage die ich die ganze Zeit im Kopf
habe haben sie ihre europäischen
Kollegen mal versucht anzurufen
und die dort zuständige
Vizebürgermeister
dort und habe festgestellt dass die
dortige Vizebürgermeisterin sich sehr
gewundert hat über die Diskussion die es
in Deutschland gibt denn sie hat selber
natürlich Belgien erklärt dass es in
Belgien selbstverständlich diese
Kostenbeteiligung gibt wie auch übrigens
alle anderen Reedereien März MSC CMA
ich bitte Sie Dänemark ist soweit ich
weiß aber wirklich
eine Demokratie
nicht abhängig von China das ist meine
was ist meine Botschaft wir sind in der
Tat im Handelsvolumen sind wir natürlich
jetzt mit dieser großen mit dieser
großen Container kommt aus China sie
sind sowas von abhängig nicht nur ein
Drittel der Container wir haben einen
hohen Export und einen hohen Import aus
China und deswegen sind wir und dann mit
dieser großen Volkswirtschaft in Europa
und in Deutschland sehr wirtschaftlich
sehr eng verknüpft das ist
frau Krüger sie wollten also das
Entscheidende ist ja auch wirklich das
große Ganze zu sehen und zu sehen das
Hamburg tatsächlich ein Puzzleteil ist
in dem ganzen und mich wundert es
überhaupt nicht dass die die anderen
Hafenstadt BürgermeisterInnen
sich wundern die haben wir die gleichen
Pläne wie sie die haben mir die gleichen
Hoffnungen wie sie und das Problem ist
ja schon das China sich insgesamt in
europäische Infrastruktur einkauft also
zum Beispiel der Hafen von Piräus der
ist ein ganz wichtiges Tor für China
nach Südosteuropa und da entstehen jetzt
Eisenbahnverbindungen da investiert
China wirklich in die Infrastruktur um
da tatsächlich quasi die ganze
Lieferkette zu kontrollieren bei dem
entscheidenden Unterschied zu Hamburg in
Hamburg verkaufen wir keine
Infrastruktur naja die Straßen die
Brücken die Schienen die Straßen
100% städtisch der Betrieb des Habens
ist hundertprozentig wir haben deswegen
ist eine Unterschied zu Piräus diese
Hafen ist erst entstanden und groß
geworden durch chinesische Investitionen
das ist eigentlich doch
groß wird Triest groß das ist doch genau
das was man weltweit überall sehen kann
wenn sie sagen es geht hier nicht um
Schienen und Kräne und so weiter sehen
ganz ehrlich also darum geht es wirklich
nicht es wurde aber behauptet dass es
darum geht und deswegen muss man sagen
wir haben wir haben 2022 es geht um
Daten
und zu den Daten kann ich Ihnen
bestätigen dass wir
Daten doch nicht irgendwelche Kräne der
Chef unseres Hafens ist ein IT-Experte
und wir haben die beste cybersicherheit
die man im Hafen haben kann es gibt
durch eine Beteiligung in einem Terminal
kein unterschiedlichen Datenfluss
gegenüber den Räder rein sie bekommen
die Daten die sie vor und nach der
Beteiligung haben und das gilt für alle
anderen Rede rein also
Hamburg sind große traditionsreiche
Hilfe okay warum machen das ist ein
anderes Thema gewesen weil pureus ganz
gezielt China sozusagen eingeladen hat
dort im dreistelligen Millionenbereich
Infrastruktur aufzubauen auf deutschen
Druck über ganz Klammer zu die haben
immer und das ist eine andere eine
andere Konstellation am Hamburger Hafen
oder in Rotterdam oder ein Pferd mit der
Fall ist okay dann die simple Frage was
glauben Sie warum machen die Chinesen
das
ich glaube sie brauchen und sie wollen
sicherstellen den Zugang zu den
Weltmärkten ihre große Volkswirtschaft
für sich alleine ist nicht so stark wie
eine gute Verbindung in die Weltmärkte
und aus dem gleichen Grund müssen wir
sicherstellen dass wir als viertgrößte
Volkswirtschaft der Welt die auch Ex und
importorientiert ist dass wir diesen
Zugang auch behalten deswegen hat der
Hamburger Hafen eine nationale Bedeutung
es gibt nicht darum dass wir nur in
Hamburg den kleinen Blick haben und
deutsche Hafen ganz genau und deswegen
ist es wichtig dass wir effizient
arbeiten können dass die Bundesregierung
sich jetzt engagiert wir haben viele
Themen wir brauchen kühl-brandwährung
wir brauchen
Management wir brauchen der deutschen
Bundesregierung und ich freue mich dass
die Diskussion jetzt dazu geführt hat
dass sich die Bundesregierung stärker um
den Hafen kümmert als sie es je vorher
getan hat sechs Ministerien
die alle sagen macht das nicht
Geheimdienste die sagen macht das nicht
europäische Partner die sagen macht das
nicht Amerikaner die sagen macht das
nicht der Bundeskanzler der sagt mir 35
Prozent geht nicht macht das nicht
mach im Zweifel haben die alle keine
Ahnung wir haben alle keine interne
Kenntnisse über die Frage wie wir
unseren Hafen organisieren und ich kann
Ihnen sagen wir sind als Stadt haben sie
die internen Erkenntnisse weitergegeben
wir sind da ein bisschen aktiv Angeboten
auch in der Schlussphase noch einmal an
der Beratung teilzunehmen und dieses
Angebot ist jedenfalls zum Schluss nicht
hier angenommen worden das wollten die
alle nicht wissen nicht
verfahrensbeteiligt ist sie haben
richtigen halswirkungen dieser
Geschichte nein ich merke nur dass sie
sozusagen auch es ist eine Ablenkung von
der Kern Diskussion wir müssen ja die
Strategie prüfen wir brauchen eine China
Strategie wir müssen noch analysieren wo
wir abhängig sind und wo wir kritisch
abhängig sind wir sind es aber nicht im
Container Transport ich lasse jetzt auch
in Ruhe mit der Geschichte
trotzdem noch die Frage
wie haben Sie Scholz davon überzeugt
dass gegen sechs Ministerien einfach
durchzudrücken ich habe ihn davon nicht
überzeugt sondern er hat ich habe vor
einem halben Jahr mal gefragt wie weit
ist eigentlich diese Genehmigung denn
das war lange veröffentlicht stimmt
Kostprobe beteiligen das ist vor einem
Jahr gewesen 35%
Frage gestellt und jetzt kam plötzlich
dieser Mainstream auf dieses Problem
dass man denkt jetzt müssen wir ganz
besonders vorsichtig sein und ich kann
nur sagen wir müssen vorsichtig sein ja
man hat vor einem Jahr naja es ist ja
was passiert
was passiert genau deswegen ist sie
jetzt sozusagen in dem
was heißt Stream ist das Moment das vor
zwei Jahren kein Mensch darüber
gesprochen hat dass China eine große
Bedrohung ist die deutsche Politik
konnte gar nicht sich vor alle haben
sich vorgedrängelt Teil der Seidenstraße
Initiative dann ist am 24 Februar ein
genau
ist eine völlig neue Diskussion in
Deutschland losgebrochen die ich gut und
richtig finde die aber nicht an einem
falschen Beispiel geführt werden
die Beteiligung Couscous am an diesem
Terminal ist ein falsches Beispiel es
ist geradezu eine Schwächung so eine
Struktur nicht zuzul